at dawn somewhere deep within the Mekong
River Delta a South Vietnamese river
assault group moves against the Vietcong
with it goes a young American Navy
lieutenant he serves in a guerrilla war
of seek and destroy
yet here far from destroyer an aircraft
carrier he is the American Navy in
Vietnam
on the Yankee station somewhere in the
South China Sea
another's more familiar view of the
American Navy in Vietnam the mammoth
Kitty Hawk second largest of us attack
carriers turns into the wind the launch
its airborne striking force
[Music]
not far away along the coast other units
of the u.s. 7th fleet take careful aim
on call from troops fighting ashore and
place supporting fire on Viet Cong
concentrations
farther south another kind of arm
strength prepares to go ashore the most
effective means known for gaming and
holding a piece of ground the individual
fighting man the United States Marine
there's a pack militant officer Alan
speakin can I officer inland that Saigon
a navy chief works at a different kind
of job less glamorous but vitally
important it was they assign this little
hope you sir behind the guns and planes
and fighting men is a staff of Navy Army
and Air Force personnel who administers
support activities for Allied forces
throughout the country and you nature
envy announcer be honest be honest here
this is for the baby east of Saigon and
a small village near the coast
these men have gone beyond the basic
mission of military action to launch an
equally important campaign of civic
action another side of the American Navy
in Vietnam to these men their work on
projects which will result in civic
achievement is just as important as the
work their shipmates do in more
conventional naval surroundings I'm Chet
Huntley the most of us this is the
United States Navy the aircraft carrier
the cruiser and destroyer the modern
deepwater Navy
extending American strength across the
oceans of the world but in Vietnam the
American Navy has done an unprecedented
variety of different jobs
it has held command responsibility for
all support activities with the army it
has been advisor to the South Vietnamese
and has sent the Marines to help fight
the land war with the Air Force it flies
the planes which provide air power
and with civilian agencies it pursues a
vigorous program of civic action these
are the all around the capabilities
demonstrated by a modern versatile naval
force in action the American Navy in
Vietnam
my
July 1964 off the coast of Vietnam units
of the United States 7th fleet patrolled
waters of the South China Sea to help
the people of South Vietnam defend
themselves against the threat of an
armed communist takeover the United
States and other countries have begun a
flow of economic technical and financial
aid a giant civilian military effort to
build a stronger nation a small but
dedicated South Vietnamese Navy is hard
at work in an effort to deny the use of
the rivers and coastal waters as supply
routes for the Vietcong to bring
knowledge of new techniques which can
increase efficiency a United States
military assistance command has been
established American Navy advisors work
with the Vietnamese and help in many
phases of training
heads to packed the United States Navy
headquarters support activity has been
established in Saigon already in mid
1964 the American Navy is in Vietnam
at the end of July 1964 the United
States military assistance command
reports an increase in Vietcong forces
in South Vietnam then the Navy's role in
Vietnam suddenly expands
on August 2nd the United States Navy
destroyer Maddox on patrol and
international waters of the gulf of
tonkin begins to track three unknown
craft approaching from the northwest
they are identified as North Vietnamese
PT boats armed with torpedoes and 37
millimeter guns when warnings from the
Maddox fail to stop the oncoming PT
boats she opens fire
the attack prompts the United States to
strengthen its ready defense
capabilities the destroyer was carrying
out of a mission of patrol in those
waters and international waters when it
was attacked replied to the attack it
continued to carry out its mission today
and will do so the remainder this week
in the same waters the president has
asked the destroyer force be doubled and
with an air cap a combat air patrol be
available at all times on call to it and
as I think you know he's issued
instructions that in the event of a
further attack upon our vessels and
international waters we were to respond
with the objective of destroying the
attackers the maddox joined by the
destroyer C Turner joy resumes its
routine patrol but the next night the
men on watch in the two destroyers once
again detect unidentified contacts on
radar we attacked by the North
Vietnamese boats is renewed
after a three-hour running battle which
two of the PT boats are sunk the
attackers break contact
my fellow Americans as president and
commander-in-chief it is my duty to the
American people to report that renewed
hostile actions against United States
ships on the high seas in the Gulf of
Tonkin have today required me to order
the military forces of the United States
to take action in reply the performance
of commanders and crews in this
engagement is in the highest tradition
of the United States Navy but repeated
acts of violence against the armed
forces of the United States must be met
not only with the earth defense but with
positive reply by the end of March 1965
air operations from navy carriers in the
South China Sea are underway on a daily
basis
also in March in operation dagger thrust
an integrated Navy Marine Corps effort
seventh Fleet Marines land at the nine
let it chill I and later on the fumu
peninsula on land the Allied forces
fight to turn the tide of conflict from
a retreating defense against guerrilla
attacks to an offensive strategy
designed to defeat the Vietcong during
1965 the United States Navy with its
ability to move quickly on short notice
is called upon to reinforce the United
States position in the short time since
the Tonkin Gulf incident American naval
power rapidly expands from a supporting
role to a full-fledged naval task force
[Music]
embodied in the forces of the United
States seventh Fleet is almost every
facet of modern naval power cruisers
like the USS Canberra are built for fast
speeds and long endurance the destroyer
indispensable to any naval action is the
workhorse of the fleet the USS
Bainbridge a destroyer leader is largest
of the destroyer class the world's first
nuclear-powered guided missile frigate
both cruisers and destroyers in addition
to their traditional deepwater roles
have been called upon to play a special
role in
Delta this is gamma tear sex charlie
target number two zero one during one
three whatever the need arises ships of
the seventh fleet moved quickly into
position along the coast of Vietnam take
their directions from the forward air
controller or spotter who is in visual
contact with the animators fiber effect
this is naval gunfire support a mobile
source of big gun reinforcements or
friendly troops ashore meanwhile
standing farther offshore is the heart
of the fighting fleet in Vietnam as
never before the aircraft carrier has
proven her worth from a huge Kitty Hawk
to the even larger nuclear-powered
enterprise the Navy's attack carriers
have held the balance of power samurais
I'm here for mrs. a18 great then feel
the jet and takes an exhaust a fourth
graders are here for a fictive day one
and A three
fast mobile independent of political
boundaries and agreements the carrier
can ready her flight deck on short
notice
launcher airpower as required the modern
attack carrier is a carefully
coordinated organization of countless
complex pieces of hardware and of
hundreds of men who make the hardware
work-related on
while watching for flash flow throughout
the world hi there stacks up rather from
yeoman to machinists mate
many of the men below decks work at the
important traditional jobs familiar in
naval ships throughout the world but in
the IFF non-contact three-30 other men
must master newer skills and disciplines
required by new technologies in the
combat Information Center equipped with
the latest facilities for rapid
communication and data handling a
complete picture of the surrounding
tactical situation is kept up to the
minute by sophisticated electronic and
computerized systems your pigeons once
exhilarating austere halt player in
other spaces and compartments the
carrier is equipped to keep almost
anything she carries from a coffee pot
to complex avionics gear in combat ready
condition this event 7 Delta will be
running the route 14 route recce from
Pleiku down to band motto there should
be automatic weapons along the route
there's some artillery fire down just
north of ban mètode' in a sense the
final responsibility for the success of
the carrier's mission rests with a small
group of men whose job is to master the
intricate operation of a million-dollar
fighting machine the modern jet aircraft
ok everybody get your radios and get the
data down off the board here and you'll
be ready to man
the carrier's primary mission is to put
these men and their planes in the air
and on target
her mix of fighters attack aircraft and
reconnaissance planes extends the
carrier strength for hundreds of miles
they seek out the enemy strongpoints and
selectively placed striking power on
targets where it will be most effective
anime supply road some storage Devils
dams and airfields barracks and troop
concentrations
one of the best examples of the range
and flexibility of naval power is the
modern amphibious operation a
coordinated Navy Marine Corps action
designed to bring force in readiness
wherever it's needed
put it ashore and hold a piece of ground
in the years since World War two
amphibious landing techniques have been
refined modernized and speeded up in
Vietnam amphibious assaults by forces of
the United States 7th fleet have driven
the Vietcong from many strongholds along
the coast
it is typical of the cooperative effort
in Vietnam that in this operation on
Navy amphibious ship provides a landing
platform and fresh ammunition for army
helicopters which will provide air
support for United States and South
Vietnamese soldiers and Marines on shore
[Music]
one of the newest concepts in strike
warfare is built around the lph or
amphibious assault ship a completely
equipped floating helicopter base with
complete facilities for the service and
control of an airborne assault
control this is Bravo 8 - would airport
at 3 0 flight of 16 event 101 - 4 over
Bravo 8 - 1 this is clear water Roger
your pigeons to point Cairo - 8 0 1 4
over this is a - 1 Roger out in
production of the helicopter -
amphibious operations as precipitated
the greatest single tactical innovation
since the Second World War the technique
of vertical envelopment
Marines are swiftly airlifted to land
behind enemy positions while the rest of
the force assaults the beach completion
of the mission is in the hands of the
Fleet Marine the Navy's most competent
means of extending its power inland
it may be that the most unusual thing
about the American Navy in Vietnam is
the fact that it has played such an
important role in Vietnam the fact of
the Navy while it has carried out a wide
range of assignments at sea has also
contributed heavily to the effort along
the coast in the rivers and on shore one
of the most important jobs is the
continuing patrol of Vietnamese coastal
waters airborne patrols are flown day
and night around the clock to ensure
against infiltration of supplies and
ammunition from the north
quita this bluebird 3-0 request surface
units in Biscay bluebird 3-0 that's a
clean cut Roger of suspicious conduct
report sir very well thank you in Saigon
at the command center of US naval forces
Vietnam naval activities throughout the
country are coordinated harvest rippln
Bluebird free zero aircraft has a
suspicious contact here in the
restricted zone
he says a large one of the major efforts
of this command is operation market time
where the Navy's name for the important
task of coastal surveillance we have a
destroyer lwp be in the area I recommend
we send the destroyer down there to
investigate this contact in this case a
destroyer escort is assigned to examine
a suspicious contact reported by Air
Patrol Vietnamese Navy liaison officers
assigned to each American ship check
identity papers and cargo manifests to
be certain then an innocent cargo of
fish or rice does not conceal Vietcong
guns supplies and ammunition
holes are open and inspected each day
brings thousands of fishing and cargo
junks to the river and coastal waters of
Vietnam the enormous task of operation
market time is to guard against the you
so there's normal marketing activity as
a cover for smuggling an infiltration by
the Vietcong in addition to destroyers
and minesweepers market time patrols are
conducted by high speed patrol craft
called Swift boats and by cutters of the
United States Coast Guard whose crews
are well experienced in this kind of
work one of the newest additions to the
patrol efforts in Vietnam is the Navy's
PBR the PBR is a 31-foot plastic hauled
water jet propelled craft designed for
high-speed operation in very shallow
water quiet and highly maneuverable it
is used in operation game warden whose
mission is to prohibit all Vietcong
movement in the Mekong River Delta
[Music]
patrols along the coast are coordinated
with a Vietnamese Navy through its
regional coastal surveillance centers
just as naval activities at all levels
are coordinated between American and
Vietnamese control on the basic river is
headquarters for Vietnamese river
assault group 25 here and at other bases
throughout the country officers and men
of the United States naval advisory
group perform one of the most important
roles of the American Navy in Vietnam
side by side with his Vietnamese
counterpart the American advisor helps
to fulfill the mission of the river
assault group to deny the waterways and
hiding places of the Mekong Delta to the
Vietcong we I suggest we alert the right
controls to keep the pencil eye on this
area the next couple knife
a typical operation begins shortly after
midnight as troops load aboard the
assault boats and start upriver by the
next morning the assault group which has
moved several miles upriver to close
with a Vietcong force launches its
attack
[Music]
in terms of numbers these men who ride
the river assault boats are few in terms
of the overall Navy commitment their
contribution is great at a junk Force
Base in a delta near the small fishing
village of Jim Tom another US naval
adviser lives and works day in day out
with the men of Vietnamese coastal group
37 with his counterparts the base
commander he takes part in every phase
of the daily routine it was all okay
together they carry out the daily
patrols constantly checking against the
possible infiltration of Viet Cong
supplies on the river waterways together
they share the meals prepared by the
commander's wife where we entered into
the right Vietnamese name this year to
date she made up okay well Spanish army
always these guys are together they
relax when time permits discuss their
work and the small matters of personal
concern which often seem insignificant
but which help to bridge the gap between
their two widely separated words other
advisors at the Vietnamese Naval
Shipyard in Saigon put their experience
and skills to work contribute their
knowledge of improved shipbuilding
techniques and new construction
materials develop procedures to help
increase shipyard efficiency
[Music]
at July and Danang at I mean and Pleiku
from the Delta to the Central Highlands
the Seabees naval construction experts
are at work on a wide variety of vital
projects often working behind the scenes
the Seabees don't make headlines but
without the things they do make the
headlines might never appear from
airfields and roads to hospitals and
storage depots the Navy construction
battalions move from project to project
pursuing the accomplishment of their CB
model can do in addition to the Seabees
the Navy also staffs the OIC see officer
in charge of construction which
supervises civilian contractors in the
world's largest single construction
program the OIC see plans and builds
military facilities throughout the
country
at Saigon the Navy has established the
major medical facility for United States
and allied personnel the quality of
medical service in Vietnam has reduced
mortality from battlefield casualties to
an unprecedented low by the end of 1965
head soo packed the in-country support
activity has gone into the Navy's
largest single overseas shore command
and by June 1966 when it has been
officially turned over to the Army it is
serving a chauffer mechanic
administrator electrician doctor
and policemen it is generating electric
power providing warehouse facilities
operating an airline and performing
other services for thousands of Allied
personnel to the north at the port city
of Da Nang another United States Naval
Support Activity has been activated and
is growing rapidly these facilities
which will meet the demands of an
expanded logistics support operation
include provisions for another large
naval hospital for the officers and men
of the Navy and Marine Corps who serve
on Shore the campaign in Vietnam is not
only military in nature see the
technical assistance teams have helped
with scores of civilian projects which
will improve conditions for the South
Vietnamese people roads bridges
buildings security Hamlet's to provide
safety from Viet Cong terrorism
clinics conducted by Navy doctors
dentists and corpsman have brought
medical treatment and supplies to areas
where they might otherwise never have
been through people-to-people projects
of many kinds these men are working to
win the confidence and restore the hopes
of the vietnamese through joint civilian
military action this too is the American
Navy in Vietnam
[Music]
in terms of the variety and scope of the
experience Vietnam has already written a
new chapter in the annals of naval
history never before has the potential
of the navy-marine team been so fully
realized and yet one important thing
remains unchanged the success of the
overall effort will rely as it always
has upon the acts of the individual man
whatever credit is due will rest with
many thousands of individual men who
stand behind the aircraft the ships the
boats and the rifles from the Delta to
the South China Sea and whether he
serves ashore or in the rivers and
coastal waters at sea or in the skies
above he will shoulder the
responsibility for final success or
failure and he will be the one to make
the needed sacrifice and it is important
to remember that no matter what his job
or where his duty he is the Navy's
greatest single asset the individual man
this is the American Navy in Vietnam
moving quickly where and when needed
displaying the flexibility of modern sea
power controlling the seas
extending its influence on land and
holding superiority in the air a
threeway force for peace geared to meet
aggression at any spot on the globe